i can see the end zone yep i can see it
yep
i might eat the whole thing
hear that
that was awesome
and now i'm rethinking it
[Music]
this next one
is to bomb beyond insanity yeah
i think i've seen it before on this show
so this is that one okay it is that time
oh [ __ ] all right here we go it looks
like a problem look at this thing
yeah especially the bottle it looks like
poison
it doesn't have ghost pepper
there's something going on with this one
though
all right all right all right let's look
you can only
it's hard to explain i got a
decentralized one here
right there why are you eating so much
of it that's what the people came to see
oh god
oh god
oh my god yeah this is a wild one
this is [ __ ] hot
i'm telling you
oh bro
it's all hot sauce that's a crazy one
that's a crazy one what
stop
calling me because i'm dealing with some
moral discomfort
it's like another little sip of milk on
that one it's like some wine you know
you got swishing around yeah yeah yeah
i love ranch you could use it right now
don't know why you didn't have it can i
drink ranch dressing there you go
hitting the ranch
a first time nope
that's a bad idea
what is this the antidote to
[Music]
whoa
i'm sorry sean there's a lot of no no
make no apologies i apologize make no
apologies that's just the beginning as
well
right
[Music]
just growing from here yep insane beyond
insane beyond beyond it lives up to the
name that she's still hot it's a it's a
weird show i know i'll tell you what
the hot sauce really [ __ ] with your
brain it does and it's capability of
being able to answer which is really a
clever aspect of the show
see what you've done here
i can't talk bro
you're killing your gus then we're just
blowing our conversation oh
my gosh
oh my god oh my god be careful around
the eyes too this is the part where i'll
say be careful around the eyes you don't
want right
did you catch it i don't know
i don't know
yes
you want to take a break no come on hell
yeah this is impossible yeah yeah when
does this go away it can't get hotter
than that yeah no you're right i think
that that's maximum levels and now i get
why people start to pause around this
time
holy hell
ah give me a second sure holy [ __ ] i
feel like i've i feel like a failure man
let me just
find some peace for a minute which is
fine find it
meditation meditating it's like getting
your heart broken for the first time
just kind of stay with it yeah you just
stick with it you know find yourself a
nice friend exactly we'll support you
through it and i'm right here i'm right
here with you am i crying
you look great you look great
sometimes you just have to laugh
sometimes you just have to laugh
now i feel like i've drank the lava of
mount doom this has hit me in a big way
that shouldn't be classified as food
that should be classified as a weapon
[Music]
hot ones truth or dab the game the kick
comes complete with 250 question cards
and then here's how the game works you
just go around the table you take turns
being the host being the players and
when you're a player you get asked a
question you have a choice just like in
the show answer it honestly or suffer
the wrath of the last dab and take a
look at this there's even a mini bottle
of the last dab included i suggest you
have napkins on hand you have to have
some milk on hand and of course be
careful be very careful around the eyes
hot ones truth or dab the play at home
game is available at shop.firstwe
fees.com heatness.com and amazon play at
your own risk wings not included